who's a celebrity that came to see you
guys backstage or you found out that was
a fan of the show that kind of most
surprised you
i mean we we did a show in l.a a few
years ago and we had heard that gary
busey was a fan
gary busey should be on the
we've show met him before he came
backstage right before i mean we're
minutes from showtime he comes backstage
the first thing he gives all bear hugs
then he picks me up like a rag doll he's
a big guy
throws me around throws me to the ground
and then climbs on top of me
and proceeds to tickle me straight for
five minutes
do you know how painful it is to be
tickled for five minutes but yeah
because somebody did that to me once but
um that also happened on our show i
think he was trying to grab robin or
howard or something he didn't throw one
of his acronyms at you you know
yeah
we got this i got posters of them signs
yeah
it's just funny that you led with gary
busey when we know for a fact that paul
mccartney loves the show
[Music]
that he loves the show he watches it on
his tour bus he said he says he's a big
fan and loves it and uh you led with
gary busey that's great gary's great no
yeah it has the only reason you bring up
mccartney is that mccartney uh
loves q the most out of all yeah that's
awesome he got word back that i'm his
favorite so i like to bring him up at
any at any point